wenn ich heute und morgen und übermorgen
immer was anderes erzählen kann weil es
mir gerade passt und weil ich dann vor
Ort die Punkte mache dann ist das nicht
das was ich von Politik erwarte gute
Politik beginnt im übrigen glaube ich
dort wo mein Leuten und das fand ich
sehr ehrenwert was Sie gesagt haben sie
dahin gehen und sagen ich habe das so
ich werde das mittragen weil ich bin
überzeugt davon dass das so richtig ist
so das macht aber kaum noch
jemand ich erlebe manchmal innerhalb von
einer Woche ohne jetzt Namen nennen
wollen denselben Redner oder die selben
Rednerin vor wechseln im Publikum und
denke
manchmal ich habe irgendwie eine
Halluzination oder stimmt irgendwas mit
mir nicht weil wechseln unter Umständen
Position in von 48 Stunden so schnell
kommt man gar nicht mit aber die Leute
kommen dit und die Leute nehmen das war
weil sie hören zu und das ist ja das das
ist das was meine Botschaft ist noch
hören Sie zu